en donde estaban ustedes a los 18 años
en mi vida imaginé estar frente a
cientos de personas intentando
compartirles una idea y si le soy
sincera ciento del mayor nervio del
mundo
qué loco no pues ya estoy aquí parada
el día de hoy ustedes están esperando
que yo les comparto una idea
extraordinaria e inigualable y sólo
tengo 18 años por dios
así que el día de hoy les voy a platicar
qué es lo que ha pasado en estos 18 años
y por qué estoy parada aquí
y oigan una pregunta más antes de
comenzar
y antes de que las respondan les pido
que cierren los ojos y reflexionen
en donde estaban ustedes a los 13 años
que estaban pensando que estaban
estudiando
tenían los mismos amigos que ahora
tienen o tenían la misma novia o novio
que ahora tienen
yo personalmente a los 13 años
me encontraba viviendo la etapa de la
secundaria como la mayoría de ustedes
pero reflexionen que hacían realmente a
los 13 años
les preocupaban las mismas cosas que
actualmente les preocupan
no verdad
en mi caso a los 13 años de edad me
encontraba sentada en un aula de clases
donde cada día mis compañeros y yo
recibíamos una gran cantidad de
información pero una gran cantidad de
información misma que la verdad no nos
parecía para nada interesante
porque no se llevaba la aplicación y la
mayoría nos encontrábamos muy muy
desinteresados de lo que ocurría en el
mundo exterior y de las problemáticas
globales que nos rodeaban
y yo me preguntaba por qué las clases
que recibimos no marcan nuestra vida
porque no nos motivan estas clases
estos cuestionamientos estuvieron en mi
mente esa clase cuando lo pensé la
siguiente la siguiente semana hasta que
un día decidí a observar y descubrir
que realmente no nos llaman la atención
porque nos sentamos a solo recibir
información y tomar notas
qué triste no porque es algo que sigue
sucediendo hasta el día de hoy y que
probablemente le sigue ocurriendo más
jóvenes y en más aulas de clases
particularmente en mi clase discutíamos
mucho sobre la protección ambiental tema
que para mis compañeros era muy muy muy
pero muy muy aburrido y tomar acción
pues es algo mucho más lejano
hasta que un día me pregunte
qué es lo que debíamos hacer porque a
los jóvenes no nos interesa cuidar el
medio ambiente o qué es lo que sucede
porque no nos motivamos a hacer esto
y decidí de observar y descubrí qué
que habría que impulsar alternativas y
romper ese esquema en nuestra ola de
clases en solo recibir información somos
jóvenes y el aprender de temas
importantes tiene que ser de una manera
interactiva tiene que ser algo
interesante nuestras clases tienen que
llamar nuestra atención
llama nuestra vista y motivarnos y les
pregunto las clases que han recibido
durante toda su vida realmente los
motivan realmente les dicen hoy si puedo
hoy si puedo cambiar hoy si impulsó una
idea
y
un día durante una clase escuché una
frase
que marcó mi vida esa frase me dejó
grandes sentimientos que aún no puedes
no puedo describir los pero si se los
resumo un poco enojada triste y con
ganas de demostrar lo contrario de
aquello que escuche
decían que la contaminación ambiental
crece cada día más y a los jóvenes no
les interesa aunque no importa porque
tampoco son capaces de crear cambios
y ahora que lo analizo y lo pienso
agradezco mucho esta frase en mi vida
porque fue la chispa que me motivó a mí
a levantarme y hacer un cambio en
aquello que yo escuche
y saben cuál podría ser la diferencia
que puedo hacerla para marcar la
diferencia en este aspecto pues se puede
resumir en unas cuantas palabras
impulsar educación ambiental de forma
atractiva atractiva para los jóvenes y
con este pensamiento a los 13 años tuve
una de las ideas más grandes que he
tenido durante toda mi vida o eso creo
yo pero es una idea que me apasiona a
los 13 años de edad
desarrolló un programa educativo de
cultura ambiental para enseñar a los
jóvenes cómo cuidar el medio ambiente de
una manera interactiva una manera que
les parecía divertida y una manera para
motivarlos a crear proyectos y que se
unirán a los retos del desarrollo
sostenible
toda la dinámica de aprendizaje de este
proyecto gira en torno juegos vídeos
talleres
y demás herramientas educativas que las
contara yo creo que nos llevaríamos aquí
una clase pero no es así
lo especial de todas estas herramientas
educativas y de todo este programa es
que realmente me apasiona
me apasiona
el impulsar la educación ambiental y
transmitir eso que yo veo
sin embargo
no es más no es muy fácil
y suena más fácil plasmarlo y platicarlo
porque cuando estaba parada practicando
lo que yo iba a transmitir lo que yo les
iba a contar hoy reflexione que es más
fácil pararte en un escenario y decir lo
que tú has hecho pero es pero realmente
no no es sólo eso detrás de ti hay
muchos cuestionamientos
y muchas problemáticas que se te han
presentado
al exponer o presentar una idea para mí
no solamente fue crear un programa
y conseguir el apoyo para hacerlo
realidad
voluntarios
presupuesto capacitaciones
todos estos pequeños problemas
parecían gigantescos para mí cuando me
tenía que enfrentar a un gigante estigma
social que me decía eres un rap eres
sólo una niña y ese estigma social
le restaba muchísima seriedad a mi idea
y también pues las bonitas críticas y
cuestionamientos estaban a la orden del
día siempre me preguntaban cómo una niña
va a cambiar algo tan grande and así
sabes que tú no puedes hacer eso si
sabes lo difícil que es tener resultados
al presentar esos tipos de proyectos
y al mismo tiempo cuando estos
cuestionamientos llegaban a mi vida
yo me respondía que al ser joven se te
presentarán muchos cuestionamientos
acerca de lo que propones y quién eres
es cuestión de nosotros demostrar que
somos aptos y capaces de defender esa
idea que nos apasiona
sin importar edad e imagen o posición en
la que nos encontremos
y también tener en mente que el
conocimiento no es suficiente es
necesario poner el corazón en ellos para
hacer algo realidad
y aunque a mis 13 años
me enfrenté a problemas que parecían
gigantescos fui capaz de demostrar que
mi idea era una alternativa viable buena
con poder y con muchísimas ganas de
tomar el control mismas cosas que
también nos caracterizan a los jóvenes
que queremos mover nuestro entorno
y por eso les pregunto
que los motiva a ustedes para decir hoy
yo si puedo cambiar algo que te motiva
cada mañana a decir
y mi idea es buena
saben que es algo que caracteriza a la
juventud
las ganas de hacer las cosas
y si eso te caracteriza
de qué manera tú haces las cosas
gracias a esto
a mis 13 años puedo decir que mi voz
salió de la caja
mi voz salió de la caja que representa
está en mi vida
mi voz salió de la caja porque comencé a
ver las problemáticas que estaban en mi
aula de clases como posibilidades y no
como situaciones para abandonar algo que
me gusta o como para decir que lo haga a
alguien más
si algo no está bien
nosotros debemos los que debemos
impulsar el cambio
la vida es una decisión que se puede
transformar
y se puede ver de distintos prismas
es cuestión de nosotros ser agentes de
nuestra propia transformación
y de qué manera llevas tú tu
transformación
que te potencializa
para cristalizar tus objetivos
reflexión en que los potencializa
ustedes
el comenzar a trabajar la educación
ambiental en mi comunidad siempre
representó un reto para mí
porque imagínense a mis 13 años
impulsando algo que la verdad si era
difícil y si ahorita me veo chiquita a
los 13 años me veía más como de este
tamaño de este pelo una niña de 13 años
intentando decirle a maestros
adolescentes y demás personas adultas
qué hacer qué cultura adoptar
y ese no era el reto cada vez se hacía
más grande cuando tenía que ir a otro
estado
u otro país y que me enfrentaba a
distintos retos
de idiomas personalidades y costumbres
y entendido que entre más grande es el
reto más grande es el camino de
aprendizaje que obtendrás
y ese camino de aprendizaje me ha
resultado la mejor decisión de mi vida
siempre me ha gustado mucho aprender la
verdad eso es algo que me caracteriza me
encanta aprender y en este en este
camino también descubrí un área que me
ha encantado y ha significado muchísimo
en mi vida estas son las ferias de
ciencias las ferias de ciencias fueron
un espacio donde puede dar divulgación
científica mi idea y compartirla con
personas de todo el territorio mexicano
y parte del extranjero
y hoy les puedo decir
que este aprendizaje es el porque hoy
estoy aquí parada estoy aquí parada
porque fui capaz de ver las
problemáticas que estaban alrededor de
mí más allá de lo que mi aula de clases
y mi entorno me decía
y yo les pregunto
se animan a presentarle de una manera
verdadera las problemáticas a los
jóvenes que les rodean o si eres un
adulto o joven que estás aquí sentado de
qué manera ves las problemáticas
o realmente las ves
nuestro planeta ha expresado diversos
gritos de auxilio y la madre naturaleza
se ha manifestado en múltiples ocasiones
y creo que todos somos testigos de ello
y esto hoy no se exige cambios que deben
ser asumidos de forma seria y
comprometida
está en mí en ustedes y en todas las
personas que nos escuchan el poder de la
vida
el poder de aportarle el mundo valor con
nuestras ideas
y yo les quiero decir
que ustedes también pueden salir de la
caja su voz puede salir de la caja
son lo que se necesita
hay que ver cómo utilizamos lo que somos
para aportar al mundo valor
y algo que yo les quiero decir y que
siempre quede en su mente es que nunca
se bajen del escenario
nunca ustedes son los protagonistas y no
dejen que nadie ni nada cambie esto
en mi corto transitar me dado cuenta que
para presentar un proyecto o cumplir una
meta trazada se te presentarán grandes
adversidades que marcarán fue
fuertemente tu vida
es cuestión de nosotros si las
utilizamos para crecer o no
yo soy una christina y frente a las
adversidades de mi mundo
y de mi aula de clases decidí ver
posibilidades en lugar de problemas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]